أجنبي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لا شيء يضاهي فتح سحر السينما
حقًا هو الجمع بين الصوت والرؤية
وحقيقة مصداقية ذلك
تظهر عندما نربط
هذه الأشياء معًا،
مشكلة الدبلجة التقليدية هي
أنك تخسر  كل ما لديك هو
حركات فم مختلفة، وأصوات
مختلفة، وأصوات مختلفة، ولا تجتمع
معًا، وما يفعله الذكاء الاصطناعي هو
في الأساس جسر بين Gap، فهو قادر
على إنشاء نسخة جديدة تتوافق تمامًا مع مزامنة
الشفاه التي تجمع بين الصوت
والرؤية بحيث
يؤديها الممثل بهذه الطريقة ويبدو أن
الممثلين قد أدوها بهذه الطريقة في موقع التصوير،
وستكون بمثابة ثورة في
صناعة الأفلام والاستمتاع بالأفلام في جميع
أنحاء العالم، إنها عملية معقدة ولكن
النسخة البسيطة هي في الحقيقة أنك
تستخدم التعلم العميق  لالتقاط نوع من الالتقاط
كيف يتحدث الممثلون عن كيفية
أدائهم والفروق الدقيقة في الأداء
بتفصيل كبير ومن البيرة سوف
يفهمون أنها قادرة على إعادة إنتاج
صور جديدة لذلك يبدو الأمر كما لو أن الممثل قال
الكلمات بطريقته وأدىها
بهذه الطريقة ولكن بطريقة  لغة مختلفة
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
أعتقد أن الاختلاف الكبير عما
يجلبه الذكاء الاصطناعي هو أنك قادر على تغيير
الأشياء بعد التصوير لتغيير
الحوار أو تغيير اللقطات وتغيير
الأشياء بعد الحقيقة وهو ما لم يكن
متاحًا على الإطلاق قبل أن يكون لطيفًا
لجلب أدوات الفيلم إلى متناول
يدك بشكل أساسي، وكمخرج ورواة
قصص وكاتب، من
القوي بشكل لا يصدق أن تكون قادرًا على
تكرار فيلم وجعله حقًا
بالطريقة التي تريدها دون أي
تنازلات، أعتقد أن ننظر إلى
خلال العام المقبل، سنرى
الكثير من هذا يخرج في البرية كما
كان وسنرى أفلامًا متعددة
تخرج على ما أعتقد بلغات مختلفة باللغة
العربية واليابانية والألمانية
وهوليوود
[موسيقى]
أوه
أجنبية
[موسيقى]